M it's
God it's
God Yousef how you
doing yeah my friend how are you doing
do you remember me uh I don't maybe if
we start talking some more it'll
probably
click all right I'm Yousef from Egypt
first of all let me introduce yourself
Asam alayum everybody I'm Muslim I'm
Yousef from Egypt and I've been
listening to your uh podcast here I'm
new to Tik Tok my English is not that
good before everybody start uh mocking
my English um English is my third
language um so yes the topic is Jesus Is
God change my mind yeah I don't have to
change your mind but I I want to comment
about my previous brother who was who
was you were speaking
about I I said before bringing you up I
don't know if you heard me I said that I
do not want to talk about the Aisha
thing he brought it up he wanted to talk
about that when we were originally
talking about Christianity but he did
want my perspective on that so I said
that let's talk about the subject for
the guests that come up I literally said
that my
friend right all right it's okay it's
okay if you want me to just to clarify
something if you may let me clarify
something I only I only I only want you
to I only want you to talk about the
subject I don't know if I was clear on
that I like I was clear okay all right
all right last time I called um I didn't
have my laptop as I was in I was not in
my office or was in at home now I have
my laptop in front of me so um let's
let's let's start by asking a question
um to make someone good or to claim that
someone is good
um what are the things that should be in
that uh human to be God if there is a
human being we wanted we want to say say
that he's God we have to witness some of
his miracles right
yes did you witness any of his miracles
yes I believe I believe I I have I have
personal miracles in my own life but if
you're just going if you're just going
on if you're just going on if you're
just going on the well Jesus says
blessed is so this is what this I like
your question Thomas said that he
wouldn't believe until he saw Jesus and
then Jesus appeared to him and then
Thomas called him and said know that
he's Jes hold on hold on well Jesus
showed him his his the hands his hands
in you know his side the holes in his
hands because he was crucified and he
rose again he was like look it's me put
your hands put your fingers in my holes
it's me put your hand in my side it's me
so so Thomas at first didn't believe
until he saw him and then Thomas saw him
and saw the miracle with his own eyes
and he called Jesus his Lord he said my
Lord and my God that's what he called
Jesus Jesus responded with him to him
and said you believe because you see me
blessed are those who believe without
even
seeing so even if I never saw
personally Jesus
himself I am blessed for believing in
who he is even without seeing
him he is my Lord and my
God I I totally I totally agree with you
but honestly how can we believe him yeah
first of all because he rose from the
dead no no no not Jesus I'm not speaking
about how can we believe someone who
said I've seen Jesus he told me that I'm
Jesus and he wrote it in a book and now
you're asking me to follow just someone
who saw something who thought that it
was a messenger and the messenger told
him that he's a God no oh no it's
because they have a ver veracity of
attestation meaning they have a lot of
testimony it's not just believing one
person but you have multiple let me let
me finish let me let me finish thank you
you have multiple witnesses that attest
to seeing Jesus and his miracles and his
claims and then you have the emergence
of the church was is evidence of his
resurrection this boom of this belief in
Jesus and as the resurrected Lord right
so you have this evidence on why you
should believe that Jesus is your Lord
and God
go I you know what I
accept Jesus as as as the the path as
the path of fright I accept Jesus that
he's one of the mightiest human beings
whoever lived the mightiest the
mightiest not one of he's the
mightiest sorry he's the mightiest not
one of he is the mest No No the the
might yes I totally agree I totally
agree but you know where where where we
we we are different I don't have to rely
on someone who did not um I rely on
Jesus Christ's words for example now
sorry I didn't get your name my name is
Yousef by the way my name is my name is
my name is Avery but you don't rely on
Jesus's words you reject them Avery yeah
just a moment let me clarify now Jesus
will return correct yeah where does
Jesus say
that in your belief not in my Jesus will
return right you believe you in your
belief you believe Jesus will return
where Jesus where did Jesus say that
question is my friend the question is
Jesus Is God change my mind I'm said you
said that you said you said that you
rely Yousef you said you rely on the
words of Jesus you just made you just
made a claim about Jesus saying that he
returns where does Jesus say that yes
you teach me in your belief does he does
he return or he does doesn't return oh
we believe that he returns cuz we have
the words of Jesus do you great great
great do you have the words of Jesus
Yousef when when just a moment just a
moment no it's not just a moment it's
not just a moment do you have the words
of
Jesus of course we do oh really okay so
where does Jesus say that he's have the
words that Jesus was saying we have the
words so where do you get it from where
Jesus says he will return we got it from
the same source that Jesus himself was
getting it from so where do you get
where where where is
it uh just a moment I I'll I'll bring it
up because I I'm one of the bad Muslims
I don't memorize the whole mus the whole
Quran Oh no you're you're you're not a
bad you're a regular Muslim no no
there's hardly any Muslims that memorize
the no no no no no believe me believe me
I'm like from the 60% population who
does not memorize the whole Quran I
would I I would say I would say I would
say 90 I would say you're part of the
90% that doesn't memorize the Quran
maybe in the US but I'm not here my
friend
um
and um but honestly you know what I'm
looking it up right now but um um
uh but uh but uh honestly this is taking
me away from the subject the main
subject because I had a point and you
you I I lost lost track of it can can I
just my back when when you say something
no I'm sorry when you say something I
have to hold you to it as a Muslim
you're saying that you you're saying
that you rely on the words of Jesus
where does Jesus say that he's coming
back um from the Bible right there you
go you get it from the Bible so you're
saying that the Bible has the words of
Jesus no ah so you see how that how you
see how you're in trouble there no no no
I'm not in trouble by the way we as
Muslims as Muslims as Muslim we believe
that Jesus was um was not crucified was
not killed yeah so you don't believe you
don't believe Jesus's words when Jesus
says I will be crucified I was crucified
and I rose again on the third day as the
script said you don't you don't you
don't believe Jesus's words this is my
point my my point is
Yousef my point is Yousef
relax my point is Yousef is that you
said and I was and I and I don't want to
I I'm trying to refrain from saying you
lied but you know I'm you know hopefully
we don't get there but I would say that
you were being
disingenuous when you said that you as a
Muslim you rely on the words of
Jesus yet I asked you where do you get
the words of of Jesus that he's coming
back you said the Bible and I'm like
okay so does the Bible have the words of
Jesus you said no now and you you
chuckle because you see the problem
there so do you so do you rely on the
words of Jesus or
not just a moment just a moment let me
clarify we have from peace be upon him
that Jesus will return I don't care
respectfully I do not care about what
any of your Hadith say where does
say where does Jesus say he's coming
back very listen my friend don't be like
this just let us have a smooth
conversation and we are trying with two
grown-ups we're trying to have a smooth
conversation you you're trying to show
your point of view I'm trying to show my
point of view this is a debate really
I'm not I'm not interested so so then so
then so then I so then I would suggest
my friend if you don't like the way that
this conversation is going I would
suggest that you I like it oh you do no
no okay so this so this so this is so
this is how this goes Yousef I will
allow you to make your point and say
what you got to say as long as you're
direct as long as you're honest so don't
waste my time I won't waste your time be
honest I'm G be honest with you so what
I'm saying is when you say we have
Hadith where Muhammad says things the
reason why I said I don't care about
that is because I didn't ask for a
Hadith from Muhammad I said where does
Jesus where you said you you said you
rely on the words of Jesus because
listen my friend where do we get our
religion as Muslims where do did we see
Jesus Christ did you see him did we did
I see him we we didn't see him but we as
Muslims we had a prophet who said from
The Source who is God the only God the
the the father from your point of view
that um Jesus will return what did I ask
you you tell me you tell me you tell me
yeah you tell me how do you follow the
words of Jesus I said Jesus said in your
Bible that he's com back so are the
words of Jesus so here we are again
Yousef are the words of Jesus in the
Bible there are some of words of Jesus
in the Bible it's either his words it's
either his words or in the Bible or not
no my friend we believe the Bible is
truth but it has been manipulated this
is what we believe we don't believe that
the whole Bible so hold on a second so
how do you know what are the words of
Jesus or
not because we have confirmation from is
who the the messenger Who Came From God
many years later after Jesus Christ he
told us that Jesus Christ would come
back so now I tell him where do where
does Muhammad say that Jesus said he
will come
back how one moment just moment
this is what I mean by disingenuous it's
a dis disingenuous argument we rely on
the words of Jesus what does we rely on
the words of Jesus where do you get this
from the Bible oh so the Bible has the
words of Jesus no what no no no I say
yes I said yes sorry I I I didn't
understand your question the first time
I told you now I told you yes it has the
words of Jesus has been manipulated
would you okay would you like to okay so
the part that's the part where Jesus
says that he's coming back you're saying
that that's the true words of Jesus is
that
correct of course okay so let me read
you let me read you where Jesus says
this let's let's see now watch watch you
switch up you said that this is the real
words of Jesus I guarantee you you're
gonna switch watch this is what Jesus
says when the son of man comes watch
okay when the son of man comes this is
Matthew chapter 25 verse starting at
verse 31 when the son of man comes in
his
glory and all the angels with
him then he will sit on his glorious
throne and before him will be gathered
all the nations and he will separate
people from one another as a Shepherd
separates sheep from the goats and he
will place the sheep on his right but
the goats on the the left then the king
will say to those on his right come you
who are blessed by my father inherit the
Kingdom prepared for you from the
foundation of the world to those on his
left he will say depart from me you
workers of iniquity H into the Eternal
fire prepared for the devil and his
angels so this is what Jesus says he's
going to come with glory in his own
glory and and he says that he will sit
on his glorious Throne on the day of
judgment and he will judge the
Nations and that he is the King on the
day of
judgment are these Jesus's
words these are man you are really
really on points but there is a small
problem when what you're saying that
this is not his return this is Judgment
Day this is Judgment Day this is his
return this is not the return on Earth
no no no no judment
my friend his return he will come back
on Earth he will yes he's going to judge
on Earth what you said right now is that
he's going to sit on his uh glorious
uhuh glorious and he will judge people
yeah on Earth the go the this is not
their return this is Judgment Day on
Earth but in Islam my friend how how
going to J he's coming to Earth where
people reside
and he's going to separate them where
are the people what planet are they
on what planet are the
people yeah yeah so Jesus is going to
come back to earth to J judge people
that's
correct and the people who died what is
he going to do with them he's going to
resurrect them so this is Judgment Day
this is not the return of Jesus on
Earth yes but this my friend Jesus so
this is something new I'm learning from
you so you believe that Jesus is coming
back and he will resurrect everyone so
you believe you want me to believe that
this Earth is going to hold every single
human being that has been created the
same Earth We're on right now which is
very crowded by the way
res yeah he's coming to Earth according
to Jesus he's coming to Earth and he and
he will
resurrect According To Jesus yep he's
coming to Earth no my friend this is
according to your book
what we believe in and what did and what
did I say you're GNA do I literally said
book is manipul what did I say I said
that as soon as I read this you're gonna
switch I said so the words of Jesus stop
I said the words of Jesus I said the
words of Jesus where he says that he's
coming back these are the true words of
Jesus right you said yes and then I said
okay I'mma read it and I said I
guarantee you you're going to switch and
lo and behold Prophet Avery is right
again you
switch man calm down it's not like this
I did not switch I still I'm by my word
I'm with you Jesus will come I'm with
you you're not with me because you
reject the word of let let let me
elaborate let me elaborate please my
friend
what sorry guys had to restart because
there's a little bit of a delay he was
destroy the cross he will um
will Slaughter the swine and then he
unit you what what's my argument what's
my argument I don't care I don't I don't
care about the Islamic point of view
what's my argument see see this is what
I've been doing I've been trying to
negotiate your argument and you've been
trying to take me into loopholes what's
AR how how did you get the Jes what's my
argum Jesus has got to change my mind
Jesus God change my mind heyf take care
yourself let me ask you the question
again take care get out here
really take care of
yourself we saw enough thanks for
proving me to be a prophet again I said
that you were going to switch and show
your
disingenuousness one second one second
my brother I'm pretty good I said I
showed you I said that you were going to
switch as soon as I read the words of
Jesus and you did exactly that oh well
no this has been manipulated it but you
said at first these were the true words
of Jesus talking about his coming now
all of a sudden because it disagrees
with you it's been manipulated you
Muslims are dishonest you're
disingenuous you cannot argue genuinely
you have no intellectual Integrity you
have no Integrity when it comes to the
text No Ex of Jesus you can't do it
because as a Muslim you
can't the second you're honest you'll
become an next
musl oh my God I
[Music]